[Music]
all right
let's play hmm
well let's place sicilian let's place
the ceiling
let's play sicilian
and let's go back to an accelerated
dragon i think
let's reinforce some of the concepts
that we talked about in the five minute
speed run it's been a while since we
played the accelerated which is the the
gateway sicilian that i recommend
to most people in this rating range who
are interested in trying out the
sicilian
because it's not too theoretical it's
easy to learn it features
simple to understand development moves
and it can really lead to some really
really good positions if white is not
careful
so of course if and kettle the bishop we
apply immediate pressure on white center
and okay c3 is already a mediocre move
c3 is a mediocre move
on the one hand it's not bad because it
reinforces the knight
and it takes some of the power away from
the bishop but on the other hand it
doesn't develop the knight it takes away
the c3 square from white's knight
and white's going to end up developing
very very passively
so how should we proceed with black what
should we do
and there's no need to reinvent the
wheel here the moves are very
straightforward which is one of the
things that makes this
quite uh quite appealing of course we go
knight f6
and then we castle and then we go d5 we
don't even have to go d6 in most
positions okay he blunders upon
there's no reason for us not to take
this and already this is bearing fruit
knight takes c4 and we have okay bishop
takes c6 that's
not great he's moving his bishop twice
taking him for a knight that that's only
moved once
now both three captures make a lot of
sense but i always like to prioritize
piece placement and piece activity
over pawn structure uh in most of these
instances so bc would be good
in the sense of opening the b file and
maybe paving the way for a bishop a6
kind of move
but i still like taking with the d-pawn
because taking with the d-pawn opens a
line of
line of negotiations between the queen
and queens and since we're up upon
that's probably a good idea
in addition it opens up our bishop along
a more
uh juicy diagonal so let's play d take
c6
we also have the two bishops as a sort
of as a unit now
so opening the center would make sense
thank you antutu reborn
okay castles we're going to castle as
well we don't need to do anything with
this knight it's
perfectly well placed it's undefended we
should be careful about it but
there's no way for him to fork it with
anything everything else is defended
92. what else all right
so we can trade knights there's no
reason not to but if you want to play
particularly you know in a particularly
spicy manner
uh you we can also keep the knights on
the board because
his knight on d2 is a little bit passive
it has no clear prospects
our knight is in the center it's it's
very
you know very jumpy it's very flexible
you can jump to a lot of good squares
so one move that comes to mind is to
bring it back to f6
and then reroute it to either g4 or d5 a
lot of people
might not consider this move because
it's a retreating move
but again it's a retreating move in name
only we're going to re-deploy it
on either an outpost or or in a very
strong g4 square
and by keeping pieces on the board we're
making it harder for him to to breathe
all right knight c4 uh
now we need to be looking for active
moves with our pieces
his knight on c4 feels quite quite a bit
loose
so yeah queen c7 is definitely a good
move aiming at this pawn and preparing
knight g4 that's one way to play
that's definitely one way to play what
else comes to mind
what other moves can you guys join right
now i just want us to get into the habit
of generating reasonable moves in such a
position
so bishop e6 wouldn't be great because
he can take the bishop and ruin our pawn
structure
i see megar mentioning queen d5 that's
the move i had in mind
deploying the queen into the center and
attacking the knight
um knight h5 i
don't really see the point of that
you're putting the knight on the rim
knight d5 is a great move
well let's play and you know let's play
the move that keeps the tension let's
play queen to c7
i always like putting the queen on this
sort of in this envelope
because this construction is universal
across many openings and it's very good
the pawn on c6 guards against moves like
knight b5 or knight d5
and the queen on c7 is very very safe
okay
so queen f3 he wants probably to play
bishop
f4 and attack her queen which is
something that we can
try to cut into with what move if we
if we use our calculation here we can
find a good way to
not prevent bishop f4 entirely but take
this stinger but one good move is knight
to d5
absolutely that's a great move yeah
centralize the knight stopping bishop f4
knight g4 would have also been good
and now we are ready to push our central
pawns an idea that immediately comes to
mind here is just to play e5
f5 and e4 right
all right so here goes our kd1 should we
take the bishop here or not
it wouldn't be a bad idea to take the
bishop but i don't really see the point
in that i like the placement of our
knight i think it's an
incredibly strong piece in the center
so the theme of this game is sort of
keeping the tension not trading unless
you absolutely have to
and it's time i think for us now to
start executing the main kingside plan
well the knight is strong in the center
it's controlling a lot of squares it's
defended by the pawn
and it's blanketing our position now
some of you are attracted to the move
h5 which creates the threat of bishop g4
i get it
but he can meet it with h3h5h3 doesn't
really benefit us because that weakens
black's king's side
unnecessarily if he misses the thread
then it would be justified but i don't
necessarily like playing like that
so i think it might be time for us to
start executing
our main central strategy by which i
mean
what yeah so let's start with e5 let's
get his knight out of out of d4
and then we can play f5 and perhaps
either e4 or f4
just ramming our pawns right down his
throat notice that his queen is
incredibly vulnerable here it's just
it's not very well protected
in contrast to our queen which is hard
to get to
and his pieces in general are like
bowling kegs you know you're just
rolling you know you're rolling the
bowling ball down
um his pieces just are they aren't
anchored they aren't very well anchored
so we keep pushing them away with our
pawns our pieces are very well anchored
either because they're so far away or in
the case of our knight because they're
well protected by a pawn
knight b5 we would take it knight b5 we
would take it and attack his other
knight
so i get the point but yeah so bishop c5
all right that's a good move
and we need to move our rook where
should we move it
so rook eater d8 a lot of you are saying
e8 but if you think about where this
bishop might wants to go
i would put the rook on d a to take the
sting out of bishop d6
right because then we would play rook
takes d6 and get two pieces for a rook
so you have to always ask yourself well
where are his pieces going
rather than identifying the immediate
threat which is important
you also need to and another way of
thinking about this is that the rook is
just
more uh more active on a semi on an open
file than it is on e8
the pawn on e5 doesn't need any more
defense
um because it's going to go to e4
but you know the d file does need more
protection i'll talk about that
line after the game he did fc4 on the
end of that line
uh and that led to some interesting
complications yeah yeah we'll talk about
that
okay so queen to g3
offering a queen trade
which once again we can totally consider
accepting there would be nothing
wrong with it but we've
agreed to keep the tension when possible
and play aggressively when possible so
what comes to mind
this is a move which i this wouldn't
necessarily make in one of my own games
it's
quite risky but let's see what happens
f4
now f4 covering the attack
this does weaken our e4 pawn but if we
consider the immediate
the immediate uh you know changes in the
position you know what has changed what
what can we now
do as a result of this move you look
around the board you say aha well this
bishop on ca now has the square
uh left behind by the pawn and
incidentally this also defends defense
f5
we should keep an eye on his queen it's
almost out of squares
the problem is bishop f6 perhaps some of
you are attracted by this move
it would enable queen h6 um
so let's not rush let's go bishop f5
first
but let's keep an eye on his queen
because we might be able to spring
some sort of a trap on his queen if he's
not careful
all right knight d4 this guy is good
this guy's very very good
now is he threatening anything no he's
not threatening anything knight f5 gf5
is perfectly fine for us
however it might not be a bad idea for
us to bring some beef onto the king side
just in case
so how should we what should we do here
what comes to mind in such a position
so queen f7 is a good move
but the problem there is that he got he
goes knight to d6
he goes knight to d6 and that's just a
nasty move that i don't necessarily want
to deal with
so i missed that initially which is why
i misled you guys
um let me think for a second this is not
an easy position
what i like to you know one way to think
about this is that the general problem
that we are facing is black
is that his pieces are are encroaching
on our territory a little bit too much
so if we can just push his pieces away
it's going to make it a bit easier for
us to maneuver around so let's start
with the move b6 let's get the bishop
out of c5
and perhaps we'll get one of these
knights out of its central post
that'll make it slightly easier for us
to uh to survive
now there's a downside to this which is
that this pawn on c6 has lost
the support of the other pawn now the
queen is a little tied up
but i think we'll be able to deal with
that successfully our position is active
enough okay so here
if we take the bishop then we allow him
to take our bishop i don't want to allow
that let's play gf
this is a very nice pawn box because
we've got
a pawn chain here the king is a little
weakened but
nothing we can't deal with it's not that
bad he doesn't have too many pieces on
the king's side
we can always bring the king away to h8
this is
a great example of something that would
worry a lot of players they would look
at this king and say oh this king is
really weak
but he doesn't even really have a rook
lift right our pawns are covering all
the squares on the third rank
so you have to be super concrete okay
so i but i do think that this is a great
time
uh for us to make sure that our king
doesn't
uh you know doesn't get caught in the
crossfire
so let's let's bring our king to h8 now
we're not worried about this pin
because the bishop trade is going to
happen imminently and another thing i
want you guys to notice
another thing that is often missed when
you visually sort of notice that the
king might be might look weak
it's the fact that the half open g file
it may favor
white but it also may favor black
because we can put a rook on g8
and start targeting his f1 and that's
not something that white can do to us
right but uh at the same time yeah the
guy is playing
really really well really well queen g5
is a brilliant move
okay so let me see
he's attacking this one i think we
should defend it let's go right cafe
yeah rook f8 to defend the f5 pawn
and the best option for him would be i
don't think he's gonna see this but
to trade everything and then go knight
to e5 at the end
exploiting the weak c6 pawn that would
potentially win potentially win back the
pawn but
that's a very advanced idea very
advanced idea
so let's see he does take and
blunders the queen knight d6 is a bit of
an odd move
that's a gm idea for sure
i i don't like it when we immediately
jump to conclusions guys if this guy
makes a couple of good moves that
doesn't mean anything
he might be underrated you know we
we always should should give the people
the benefit of the doubt
okay let's go f3 target the pawn
creating the
uh creating the laying the groundwork
for our lobster pins are made so what
should we do now how do we
orchestrate the lobster pins are made
just what is the most clinical way of
doing it
and this you often kind of see this when
you keep the tension it's like
eventually
yeah so between these two moves i know
that it doesn't matter when we're up a
queen but when you're not up a queen
it's uh it's a good idea to play queen
g4 because if you play queen h5
then he plays h4 and we have to waste
another move
queen h3 and now if you've done your
puzzles you'll know what the pattern is
here he stops the lobster pincher mate
but but uh in doing so he locks his king
up and now there is a very typical idea
and a very pretty idea to go rook f6
and either to lift the rook up to h6 and
give checkmate or
as i'm sure you guys are very well aware
we begin with a
what we begin with a queen sack and then
end the game with rook h6 checkmate it's
nice it's common
it's typical the rook on g1 is the
instrument of his demise right it blocks
the king from
escaping it's nice that's a good uh
it's it's a good tool in your toolkit
because sometimes
you don't have time to complete the rook
lift this
saves the tempo because it comes with
check
okay that was a nice game by our
opponent for sure
so the opening went very well for us he
he won c3 which is subpar and then
bishop b5 is very bad
the way to play for white here is to go
knight to t2 and at least defend the
pawn
and then we castle you know
generally speaking people bring the
bishop out and then you go d5 and one
fell swoop
black's got a great position here we've
had this type of position in the
five-minute speed run a million times
and um
you know this kind of stuff is easy to
play good development
etc etcetera um
so bishop b5 the blunders the pawn and
again this is a decision which
you know can be made either way you can
play bc
to to get more you know beef in the
center that's probably the better move
honestly
dc is the move which is easier to play
because you're opening up the bishop
you're opening up the center
uh and we're already up a pawn it
doesn't matter too much
okay so castles castles knight d2
and we decided to keep the tension here
knight back to f6
this knight potentially rerouting knight
to c4 we decided on queen to c7
aiming at h2 and paving the way for
knight g4
once again there were other moves here
queen to d5 would be
a fantastic move to attack the knight
and generally i'm not a big advocate of
you know moving your queen into traffic
like this but in this particular
instance
uh the knight on c4 it's hard to defend
this knight and the queen is quite
invulnerable on d5 it can't be attacked
easily so
this is almost an exception to the rule
instead we go queen c7 queen f3 is a
good move queen of three is a very good
move
um and knight to d5 is fine
you know knight g4 was also possible
knight d5
okay to d1 why not b5
because b5 is
a good idea but it weakens the c6 spawn
we ran up against this in the game
he would go 95 and all of a sudden this
pawn on c6 is incredibly weak and if you
push that pawn
well then you drop the pawn on v5 you've
got to be very careful about these kinds
of drastic pawn movements
because they usually leave behind
weaknesses knight d5
okay so now we start pushing our central
pawns e5 f5 now we go rook to d8
and again rook to e8 would have allowed
him either to go bishop d6 or even more
unpleasantly knight d6
at the end of the world and in in the
context of the specific lines maybe this
would have been
even better for black than what we did
but my idea was to
defend the d6 and we could have played
e4 yep e4 was very much possible
attacking the queen
100 possible uh and probably even better
than what we did
i i honestly forgot about e4 i forgot
about e4 i forgot that this just
counter-attacked the queen now he would
have moved his queen back and we would
have had the same issue
right here you would have again had to
decide where to put you would have had
to move the rook eventually
uh but e4 would have been a great
addition
uh great intermediate move what about
rook f7 that's
also possible but again it runs into
knight d6 and stuff so
um impossible yeah it's impossible to
anticipate i mean i couldn't anticipate
that
that that would have to happen later now
some of you
with very sharp tactical vision
indicated that bishop d6
which is seemingly refuted by this line
is
very much possible because of c4 i saw
this move
and intended e4 in this position
attacking the queen
and there was a detail that i
anticipated here because if the queen
goes back to e2
black to play and make this line
work what does black do here i'll show
you guys a very nice
example of this kind of this kind of
knight f4 see when your queen is pinned
it's very important to understand that
the knight is literally not literally
paralyzed it can still move
and counter-attacking your opponent's
queen can be a very valuable tool in
such
situations to get out of the pin however
the queen can move to h3 if it moves to
g3 great we
trade queens and the knight is free to
go but if it goes to h3
this is the detail that i missed knight
f4 is no longer effective because the
queen is defended by a pawn white's
gonna end up winning a piece
black can play f4 though and i think
that there must oh there is a way to get
out of this situation yes
black to play now we can't
move the knight to attack the queen but
we can do something very similar we
have to understand that the queen on h4
is still undefended
so we use the queen to get out of the
pin queen f6 typical technique
and if he trades then we take with a
knight on our knight is is
is fine he can give us a check but it's
not dangerous we'll we'll get out of
this situation
so if you're able to see the various
tools of getting out of the pan of
bishop f6 he goes queen h6
and uh we can't trap the queen you see
what i'm saying guys you can
you'd have to repeat moves here and then
go queen f6 or even queen e7 also does
the same thing
i hope this makes sense okay
so i have a similar game for you guys
afterwards so e4
now in one of my games i would have
traded queens but here we decided to go
f4 and bishop f5
paying your light squared bishop to your
other rook yeah it does so in terms of
how we would have gotten out of this
scenario
there is a there are two main ways to do
it the first
is to try to get this rook away from d8
which could be hard to do because he
could
double but the the main idea is to go b6
and bishop b7
right so let's let's make a couple
randomness let's say b6 whatever bishop
b7
he's got some tactics here with rook t7
but as a general concept
this is the way to get out of a pin like
this uh
but here we could go king e7 and then
try to intercept the rooks
and try to get the rook away from d8 so
it's a little bit more complicated than
i had intended
but we would have been able to get out
of it so rookie one e4
f4 bishop f5 knight d4 is very nice
and i didn't anticipate i'll be honest
with you guys i didn't anticipate that
it would be kind of hard for black to to
unfreeze
the pieces this d6 square
is a problem that square is a problem
because if we move the queen of f7 to
beef up the security
yeah the knight slides into d6 and b7
might hang and you know things just
start getting really flimsy here that
pawn on e4 is weak
so i underestimated this and that's why
we went b6 just trying to
push his pieces away a little bit i
think he should have gone bishop a3 i
think if he had gone bishop a3
he would have kept the tension on our
position
um although here we would have gone c5
shutting down the bishop and forcing it
to bite on granite
and i think this would have given us a
really nice position so maybe not
maybe this was correct okay so king h8
sliding the king away
another nice move of queen g5 targeting
where you know hitting where it hurts
we have to defend the pawn and not now
just at the moment when he was about to
recover he blunders his queen now what
should he have done takes
and now the moment the b6 is played as i
noticed to you guys the c6 pawn becomes
weak
that's a mental note that you have to
make the more such observations you make
the likelier it is that you're going to
come up with the right decision later on
so in this position knight to e5 is
super unpleasant if the pawn was on b7
here
uh that would not be a problem but pawns
don't go backwards
and even if you defend the pawn he can
still take on c6 undermining the knight
on d5
right so what can black do in this
position well we can try to go 97
but then the rook slides into d7 and if
the king goes up to f6 who can spot
a very pretty tactic for white in this
position
well i hope it's because people are
captivated and not half asleep
yeah knight c6 rook d6 is a typical
motif
and you know i think black is still
better here i think this is how we would
have played because black stroke now
gets to d2
and these pawns man these are dangerous
pawns you can advance this pawn at e3
and get a passer
black is still better here but white
gets good drawing chances in the end
game but instead of course he made
96 i don't know hallucinated maybe he
thought he was gonna give a fork on f7
forgot about the rook there whatever it
was
the tension pays off in our favor and
and we won the game
so both captivated but still trying to
sleep no you should definitely sleep
but struggling to spot these tactics in
the actual game what are your advice on
improving these
well that's where puzzles come in
there's no shortcut there's no cheat
code
toward building pattern recognition
other than to solve
thousands of puzzles and you also
have to be mindful when you're solving
puzzles you know
and also exp game experience you know
when you play a lot of games
and then you analyze those games the
engine will tell you the moments at
which you missed
various tactics and you might say oh
well i saw this in a puzzle
and i missed that in one of my games and
what could i have noticed in the
position
to allow me to see something like this
over the board games in my case
you know represented a large part of my
experience
so i can think off the top of my head of
just such an example like
you see this tactic with knight c6 rook
d6 right let's take a game that i played
in 2005
where i remember having a very similar
kind of tactic and since then that
tactic has been kind of ingrained in my
in my mind so let me
give you guys a good example so
okay this is from a game in 2005 i was
1800
and i've got sort of a good night
against bat bishop
i advanced my king my opponent who's
1800 as well brings his king to e2
kind of an inoffensive move normal
you know he didn't smile when he played
this move black to play
black to play
yeah knight takes b2 knight takes b2
rook c2
similar type of concept with a winning
rook end game
up a pawn and then this pawn is going to
be toast as well thank you mr swaggy
and so since then i've kind of
remembered this tactic and filed it away
in my mind
you've got to try to do the same thing
whether or not you see a tactic in your
game
try to file things away in your mental
library oh this is this kind of tactic
this is one when they need to look for
in this position etc etc
okay all right i have one more game to
reinforce
an idea now just to dial it back
to this situation where you bring your
knight away
from the queen pin and i hope these
games help you guys build
your mental libraries too i'm not trying
to flex all the time i'm
trying to give people various various
ways to
not you know to to put things in your
memory
okay so i have a good example of
of this kind of tactic which one of my
opponents had missed
all right all right so
let's now take a look at a game slightly
more complicated
from 2013 this was the last tournament
this is the tournament after i became a
gm
so it's round two i'm playing at this
tournament spain i'm playing a 2100
and in this position at king's indian i
decided on the move knight to d3
it's kind of a cool tactical idea now my
opponent takes it
he takes c3 now what's the idea if rook
takes d3
who can spot the reputation what's the
point
the point is to play bishop b4 pinning
the rook to the queen that's
quite elementary and if queen takes d3
which my opponent played
then you notice that the queen and the
knight are in the same file
of course i played c5 in my opponent uh
you know he lost surely thereafter but
as soon as i played c5 i realized that i
had missed something
quite nasty and my opponent plays the
correct first move but misses the
point my opponent plays what move here
so knight c6 immediately doesn't work i
simply take
you guys are seeing an element of the
right idea perhaps some of you are
seeing
this move but the funny thing is you go
from the frying pan to the fire you're
still going to be pinned
you're not going to be able to take the
rook but you're overthinking it the move
knight c6 is not necessary the same
thing goes for this move
g takes f5 you lose the knight so the
preliminary move
is what the move c5 relinquishes control
over the d6 square first you play bishop
to d6
which he did rook takes d6
and my opponent played knight takes d6
instantly which is very bad
because after queen takes d6 i have two
pieces for a rook
and i dropped back takes takes and one
move
finished the game this is what i had
calculated the line went exactly as i
planned
boom boom bishop basics resigns and even
without this move black would be winning
but this wins a piece
but in this position i was holding my
breath
because i spotted a pretty nasty tactic
that would have complicated the game
tremendously white to play who can find
the move
let's flip the board it's not knight
takes d6
but it's a pretty incredible move and
it's the move knight to f5
knight to f5 knight to c6 rook takes c6
knight to f5 is a nasty move why because
first of all
if rook takes queen knight takes queen
is check
that's what's so crucial about this move
white keeps both of his knights alive
and white is up in exchange so you might
look at this and say well that's no
problem right i can just play g2 oops i
can just play g takes f5 but now after
knight takes t6
black still has two pieces for a rook
but look at how much this pawn structure
has been ruined
then knight's going to capture this pawn
at f5 on the next move
and the position is approximately equal
right black's king side is ruined
white's pieces are active and white
climbs out of the
uh climbs out of the hall and survives
so this idea of moving a knight that's
pinned to the queen
can be a very valuable tactic to put
into your arsenal of ideas
i miscalculated yeah so bishop b4 is is
what i would have played
even here knight f5 is possible but
um but just moving the queen
is also good because then you're gonna
pry the bishop away with f3
it's it's very complicated um
so i did miscalculate here and at the
moment i played knight d3 i saw
the idea of knight f5 but my opponent
who was very high rated you know he's a
good player
but he automatically took on d6 because
the mental association is that you can't
move a knight on d4
mental library now augmented but i think
when you see these games and stuff
you know some things may stick some
things may not but
hopefully some things do stick another
thing i want to make clear
i saw this sort of feedback on reddit
and i think it's very well intentioned
feedback
don't watch this and then say okay now
i'm going to play a couple games
and i'm going to expect to win every
single game and if i don't then that
means i didn't learn anything
you never you know things take a while
to settle in
and you know and and you have to give
yourself
a chance you also have to allow yourself
to make the same kinds of mistakes
you've been making you're not going to
automatically start playing like a gm
so i think it's important to moderate
your expectations
all right